[Music]
thank you everyone and welcome to the
strange downloads lighting talk
where you're going to learn how to use
the pins package to make sure your
data science workflow remain
reproducible now i know that most of you
take reproducibility for granted
you think or you want to live in a world
where everything is reproducible
and you know to be fair we have like
great tools like our markdown which was
designed from the very beginning to be
reproducible
however you know you know you want to be
able to copy-paste stuff anywhere right
you want to be able to grab
our code and place it on a different r
session
you want to be able to grab that same
code and put it on a different machine
and that all should work really nicely
and that's the case and if that's the
world where you live you're very lucky
well let me tell you now about a very
very dark place which i happen to call
the upside down of data science
so in this world not everything is as
reproducible as it may seem
and you might find that there's code
that requires very strange
downloads so for instance in this case
we have a package
that supports python and r and when you
copy paste the code
uh it basically doesn't work right it's
going to fail because
one one thing that you find over and
over is that there's like a local file
named whatever.csv and when you run the
code it doesn't exist
so you need to scroll all the way up and
figure out like how exactly to download
the file then you download it then you
put it on a specific path you change the
code to point to that path
and when you want to rerun the code in a
different session or a different machine
you do it all over again
so is there a better way to do this well
today we're going to find a way of
closing this awful
portal to the upside out of data science
with a new pins package
which uh basically all it does it allows
you oh background come on
um it basically allows you to download a
remote resource
locally so all you have to do is say
pin and then you have a url and it
basically converts the remote url
into a local url and that's about it
then you can make use of that resource
and not only that but the pins package
allows you to cache
the resource so if you re-run the code
we're not going to be re-downloading
this over and over again
and if you happen to lose internet
connection and you run this code the
package isn't smart enough to not rerun
the code and just use the cache version
and make sure your code doesn't break
but what else like i'm sure like a lot
of you you know work with data sets and
sometimes you tidy your data set
and then you wish you could share that
with others and the pins package also
allows you to do that you can say
a pin with a specific board and then you
all you have to do is
register your board so for instance you
have boards for kaggle github rstudio
connect
azure google cloud and s3 and whenever
you
pin a remote local data set you
basically are sharing it
in these uh remote cloud providers or
products
that's about it and let's see if i can
get a little demo to work no it won't
work so thank you that's it